entre les mains de philippe chénard une
décision plutôt rare obtenu par cet
avocat auprès de la chambre de
l'instruction
la justice reconnaît pour son client
yoann temps d'aldi cancan la légitime
défense
au sol des corps criblé de balles
deux hommes qui se connaissaient et une
femme victimes collatérales de cette
fusillade
c'était le 6 décembre 2015 au petit
matin trois personnes ont été tuées dans
une boîte de nuit du lamentin le
paparazzi deux armes trouvées sur place
ont été saisis un individu est
actuellement activement recherché par
les services du srpj insisté des
services de la sécurité publique qui ont
été cosaisis sur cette affaire et selon
les premiers éléments de l'enquète
ronaldo saint-philippe dit l'américain
aurait tiré sur eddy jean zéphirin
carita mes délices et yoann quandalle
johan quandalle tirs sur l'américain
pour se défendre dit il des tirs mortels
et c'est sa thèse qui sera retenu par
les magistrats au moment des faits
monsieur joue un camp d'al était en état
de légitime défense qui avait une
première décision du magistrat
instructeur qui l'avait renvoyé devant
la cour d'assises est donc joint de
candale avait fait appel de cette
décision et c'est la chambre de
l'instruction qui a eu à connaître de ce
dossier
en premier lieu le 16 janvier dernier
qui a pris le temps de la réflexion
analyser l'ensemble des éléments du
dossier et a considéré à juste titre que
monsieur quandalle était en état de
légitime des fils yoann canal ne sera
donc pas jugé aux assises pour le
meurtre de saint-philippe dit
l'américain en revanche dans son dossier
deux autres mises en examen
l'une pour évasion l'autre pour port
d'armes prohibées le board armes
prohibées purement et simplement parce
qu'il avait une arme et que
avait pas le droit d'en avoir 8 e
deuxièmement l'évasion était parce qu'il
était sous bracelet électronique et que
ce bracelet cdh on considère qu'ils sont
des bastions
yoann quandalle du camp sera donc jugé
pour évasion il risque jusqu'à trois ans
de prison et pour port d'armes prohibées
ils risquent jusqu'à dix ans
d'emprisonnement à l'époque cette
affaire avait défrayé la chronique et
avait même éclaboussé le monde politique